sono venuto qua a raccontare la storia
di archi mille in una in una versione
ridotta perché mi piacerebbe
approfondire delle altre tematiche che
stanno dietro a chi mille che riguardano
un po il nostro futuro
rocky mila è partito nel 2015 e quello
che vedete qui alle mie spalle è un
video che è uscito ha raccontato la
nostra storia insieme un gruppo di amici
volevamo invitare i foo fighters a
tenere un concerto a cesena quindi
abbiamo chiesto a mille musicisti di
suonare tutti insieme contemporaneamente
una delle loro canzoni
questo video è diventato virale a oggi
conta oltre 46 milioni di
visualizzazioni e i foo fighters dopo
aver visto questo video hanno accettato
il nostro invito a sono venuti a cesena
tenere il concerto è stato un enorme
successo che totalmente inaspettato
diciamo e da lì è uscita una una storia
che è andata avanti e che ha visto la
costituzione di una
[Musica]
beh scusate se facciamo un po di casino
ed è partita una storia sa che a
riunisce migliaia di musicisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo
organizziamo degli eventi dei concerti
negli stadi coinvolgendo musicisti di
ogni di ogni razza di ogni genere di
amministrazione sociale via di ogni
livello di preparazione e l'obiettivo
che vogliamo dimostrare è quello che
persone normali musicisti comuni che poi
in realtà comuni non sono quando stando
tutti insieme sono bene organizzati sono
talentuosi sono motivati riescono a
raggiungere di risultati che sono
davvero impensabili riescono ad esempio
negli stadi come le grandi rockstar
quello che vedete qui dietro sono un po
di video degli eventi che abbiamo
organizzato in questi anni in italia
negli stati uniti in corea del sud in
austria abbiamo girato tanto e siamo
diventati una band globale a tutti gli
effetti quello che
ci chiediamo spesso è perché musicisti
si scrivono cioè per che decidono di
partecipare e la risposta che siamo dati
un po questa perché magari desiderano
essere più visibili desiderano
avvicinarsi approcciarsi a una sfida
oppure decidono di fare qualche cosa di
nuovo questo qui è il gancio attraverso
i quali noi riusciamo a coinvolgerli una
volta che però hanno partecipato succede
qualche cosa che li porta a rimanere
dentro rocchi mille dopo questa prima
esperienza e il motivo è il rapporto
umano che si genera all'interno di
questa comunità cioè queste persone si
ritrovano in mezzo ai musicisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo passano
due giorni o tre giorni a non fare altro
che suonare respirare musica a conoscere
nuove persone fa una esperienza davvero
reale e questo genera in loro una enorme
sorpresa ed è strano pensare che
comunque una cosa normale naturale che
bene o male rappresenta la nostra natura
riesca a rappresentare una sorpresa così
grande tanto da farmi riflettere un
attimo sul sul dove stiamo andando
in un periodo come questo in cui tra
realtà virtuali e social media se
guardiamo non so da matrix fino a black
mirror il futuro che si prospetta sembra
quello di una grande e alienazione cioè
di persone che sono sempre più lontane
ma interconnesse sempre più isolate e
solitarie
dall'altro lato vediamo che le stesse
sono sorprese e si divertono come dei
matti co hanno in realtà fanno
un'esperienza che è di tipo totalmente
opposto quindi in realtà questo mi fa
per me mi fa mettere un po in dubbio
qual è il futuro verso cui ci stiamo
dirigendo cioè saremo sempre più isolati
o invece ritorneremo a delle comunità
reali partendo da questa domanda ho
cominciato a documentarmi e guardare un
po in in giro e riflettere su vari piani
per cercare di capire se già oggi
possiamo avere qualche indicazione sul
dove stiamo andando
bene dal punto di vista evoluzionistico
noi oggi abbiamo raggiunto una sorta di
uno status di semi divinità se ci
pensiamo pensiamo l'industria genetica
nonno e adesso riusciamo a creare vita a
modificare vita però dal punto di vista
strettamente naturalisti naturale noi
siamo ancora degli animali che vivono
nell'età della pietra
se ci pensiamo l'uomo non ha subito
delle modificazioni genetiche
nessun tipo di mutazione negli ultimi
10.000 anni il gene romane con poi è
comparso 300 mila anni fa per 280.000
anni non ha fatto altro che vivere nella
savana come un raccoglitore o come un
cacciatore quindi il nostro fisico è
costruito per questo noi possiamo non è
fatto per stare all'interno di una
stanza e interagire con il mondo che
abbiamo intorno utilizzando uno
smartphone un computer o comunque
internet
anche perché la l'esperienza che ci
offre la vita virtuale riesce a
coinvolgere sostanzialmente due sensi la
vista e l'udito e il modo in cui noi ci
interfacciamo e abbiamo coscienza di
quello che si ci succede nel mondo
virtuale si misura sostanzialmente nel
numero di like che generano nelle nostre
attività
quando in realtà la vita reale possiede
una profondità molto più vasta perché
coinvolge sostanzialmente tutti i nostri
sensi ci stiamo parlando proprio di un
mondo di due mondi completamente diversi
uno che vede una separazione dal nostro
corpo è un altro quello reale in cui il
nostro corpo è perfettamente ridere
restare dal punto di vista psicologico e
sociologico esiste un fattore novità che
è molto fondamento che è fondamentale
nel decidere quella direzione in cui noi
stiamo andando alla mia generazione
quella successiva alla mia cioè quella
dei millennial è cresciuta senza social
media senza smartphone
la mia nella fattispecie è cresciuta
senza internet e senza cellulare quando
sono arrivate tutte queste cose
per me e per tutti noi per tutta la
nostra generazione è stata una enorme
innovazione che ci ha dato degli stimoli
completamente nuovi cia incollati e ci
ha resi ha sostanzialmente dipendenti da
queste realtà ma uno che nasce oggi è
che tra vent'anni sarà un ragazzo cresce
in un ambiente in cui i social media
internet all evoluzione di social media
saranno qualche cosa di oramai
consolidato un ragazzino tra vent'anni
magari in bloccherà le ragazzine
utilizzando kinder
forse però per lui questa non sarà mai
una novità quale può essere una novità
per uno che nasce oggi una delle
possibilità la levità del futuro
potrebbe essere davvero il mondo reale
cioè una persona che nasce in un
ambiente completamente virtuale online
trova qualche cosa di nuovo nella vita
reale
di esempi ne abbiamo anche oggi millenia
stanno riscoprendo i distingui nile la
messa in orazione nave mai comprato un
disco o'neal e nel 2000 nel 2018
ma perché mi sto in puntando così tanto
sul tema della della novità perché la
novità è un fattore molto forte e che
agisce a livello neurologico nel nostro
prendere azione il nostro iniziare a
fare qualche cosa perché come leggete
l'incertezza è ciò che esercita una
fortissima attrattività quando noi ci
approcciamo a fare qualche cosa di nuovo
sostanzialmente non l'incertezza del
risultato e il potersi aspettare qualche
cosa di positivo e ciò che
sostanzialmente si muove all'azione una
volta che poi riusciamo ad avere una
ricompensa positiva o sorprendentemente
positiva il suo cervello l'ala ricorda e
ci porta a ripeterla fino a quando
questo non diventa un'abitudine quando
il nostro questa incertezza si abbassa
perché le ricompense cominciano a
diventare prevedibili
il nostro cervello sostanzialmente si
abitua perde interesse e si muove per
fare qualche cos'altro quindi
se l'incertezza è un motore così forte
mi chiedo che cosa c'è di più incerto
caotico e imprevedibile della realtà che
è così basta così profonda così
imprevedibile ma adesso sto facendo una
sorta di discorso che che è quasi
paradossale cioè io sto dicendo sto
cercando di fare una previsione di un
qualche cosa che sostanzialmente è
imprevedibile
cioè la realtà come posso dire che c'è
una possibilità che si ritorni al mondo
reale e per questo mi viene in mente una
teoria molto affascinante che si chiama
teoria del caos
il caos è una teoria scientifica che è
nata negli anni sessanta per spiegare
fenomeni metereologici e poi dopo è
stata estesa ed applicata anche in altri
ambiti come quello sociologico o
economico che descrive fenomeni che sono
scott ici difficilmente imprevedibili se
non imprese imprevedibili e estremamente
complessi in cui fattori che entrano in
campo sono talmente tanti da rendere
impossibile sostanzialmente la
previsione puntuale precisa di quello
che sta succedendo
questa teoria del caos che vedete
rappresentata in un in tanti grafici
questo è uno di quelli dice che un
fenomeno caotico e molto complesso noi
non possiamo capire esattamente come si
muoverà nel futuro però possiamo capire
all'incirca in quale range di incertezza
si può muovere e questo spostamento
questa evoluzione in presenza di una
forzante che si chiama non bellissimo si
chiama attrattore strano riesce a creare
dei comportamenti che sono ripetibili o
anche ciclici questo cosa significa
portando la teoria del caos all'interno
di questa tesi
significa che il nostro futuro
se le se la realtà è davvero così
imprevedibile però il nostro futuro in
qualche modo potrebbe essere un ritorno
al mondo reale e alla vita reale perché
in questo caso la trattura è strano sta
scritto nel nostro codice genetico che
ci vuole un animale sociale quindi né
adesso stiamo magari se facendo una
grande parabola nel mondo
dell'online per poi probabilmente
ritornare ea prestare l'off line
ma attenzione c'è una cosa molto
importante perché nella teoria del caos
e nei sistemi complessi le piccole
variazioni iniziali possono portare a
lungo termine degli sconvolgimenti
incredibile la famosa teoria della
dell'effetto dell'effetto farfalla
quindi per significa che se vogliamo
tradurre in concreto quella che è la mia
tesi è quello che al mio desiderio di
ricominciare a vivere i rapporti umani
in una maniera diretta e terrena quello
che vi invito a fare quello di
utilizzare i social media in una maniera
leggermente diverso sia fare questo
piccolo cambiamento ossia non
considerarli più come un termine finale
delle nostre attività
ho un motivo per cui fare attività
quindi quello di condividere una foto su
instagram piuttosto che fare un post su
facebook ma utilizzarlo come mezzo per
fare delle attività per incontrarsi ea
fare qualche cosa di concreto e quindi
invito tutti voi di utilizzare i social
media in modo diverso e godervi una
realtà grazie
[Applauso]